newsome it admits trump doing a pretty
good job
some people nominating for the nobel
peace prize admit trump doing a good job
joe biden not so much while the governor
of california where the wildfires are
raging is saying
that trump is not not responsible for
the wildfires because obviously he's not
joe biden is calling trump a climate
arsonist donald trump warns that
integration is threatening our suburbs
it's ridiculous but you know what is
actually threatening our suburbs
wildfires are burning the suburbs in the
west
floods are wiping out suburban
neighborhoods in the midwest
hurricanes are imperiling suburban life
along our coast
if we have four more years of trump's
climate denial
how many suburbs will be burned in
wildfires
how many suburban neighborhoods will
have been flooded out
how many suburbs will have been blown
away
in superstorms
if you give a climate arsonist four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised if we have
more america blaze
if you give a climate denier four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised when more
of america is under water
trump is destroying the whole world well
what's
joe biden's argument here joe biden
who was famously accused by his own
running mate of supporting segregation
palling around with segregationists
opposing policies for integration
is now accusing donald trump of
supporting segregation
because he thinks suburban communities
ought to be able to write their own
zoning laws
and not have the federal government
steal that power up which they did
during the obama administration
that's the first part of what he's
saying and then because
everybody's making the play for suburban
voters here actually this obama biden
era rule
this power grab in the suburbs was all
about turning suburbs which
are traditionally fairly politically
split
they're purple districts trying to flip
them blue
so what is his play for the suburbs why
are the suburbs dying why are the
suburbs becoming less pleasant
not because joe biden supported a rising
china not because joe biden
famously supported shipping jobs
overseas not because joe biden
has onerous regulations and has
supported onerous regulations
from the federal government that's
making it much much harder to do
business
no not any of that it's because mean old
trump
is paling around with the sun monster
that's his argument
it's a ridiculous argument and then he
uses that phrase trump is a climate
arsonist
what is a climate arsonist a he
he he's because he's not supporting
a government takeover of manufacturing
an industry
and proposing all these huge
redistributive wealth taxes
and not supporting the green new deal 93
trillion dollars
to set up reparations for slavery i
don't know what that has to do with the
environment because trump's not doing
that then he's responsible
for the wildfires which are being caused
by global warming because science says
so
except science doesn't say so and you
know who might be starting the wildfires
not the climate arsonist but the actual
arsonists who are being arrested in
oregon
for setting some of these fires yes
not president trump he's not the one
going around burning down
the the forests some of these fires are
being set
by actual arsonists in ashland oregon
the police chief
tj o'meara announced on thursday that
there is a criminal
investigation that has been opened into
the cause of the alameda fire
because the circumstances around that
fire are suspicious
here is what the chief said we've got
good reason to believe that there was a
human
element to it we're going to pursue it
as a criminal investigation until we
have reason to believe
that it was otherwise four people have
been arrested so
far this is what the left does
the la it's like that that meme of that
guy who turns around and shoots somebody
and then he looks to the camera he says
why did you do that
why why did trump do that that's what
the left is doing
the left is committing lots and lots of
violence
the left is projecting everything that
they're doing out and they're saying why
are you doing that
i hope you enjoyed this segment of the
michael knowles show and you should know
on september 28th
the michael knowles show will be moving
from the daily wire youtube channel to
the michael noll show youtube channel
because that just makes sense doesn't it
it's right there it's right there in the
name
there is a link in the description below
head on over
subscribe to the michael noll show
youtube channel ring the bell
you will never miss another video